Breaking news out
of Jerusalem at this hour.
A final vote on that controversial bill.
Part of the judicial system
overhaul. CNN's Hadas
Gold is live for us
now with the very latest.
So Hadas, the vote
we were talking about, the vote
moving up
a little more quickly than anticipated.
Yeah, the vote has actually now passed.
64 to zero.
This vote
that will take away
the Supreme Court's ability
to stop government actions,
declaring them unreasonable
it has passed
the reason
it was 64 to zero votes
because all the members of the opposition
left the floor in protest to this vote.
We are just outside the Supreme Court
organized us here
have set up big screens
so that protesters can see
what's happening on the parliament.
And you can hear that
they are getting very loud
and they are actually all starting
to walk down
towards the parliament building.
They don't seem to be indicating
that they're going to be leaving
any time soon,
despite the fact that this passed.
It appears
that all at times that last minute
negotiations failed
We know that there was lots of back
and forth with the coalition opposition
to try to negotiate potentially a delay.
Those appear to have failed.
The government has managed
to pass the first aspect
of this massive judicial overhaul.
This isn't the only part
of the judicial level.
One bill of several
we're seeing on the screens
of what's happening on the parliament
for coalition members
congratulating each other,
including Benjamin Netanyahu,
just out of the hospital
actually for a pacemaker.
That was just a tally.
He literally left the hospital
this morning.
They came straight to the parliament
when this vote passed out.
This does not mean necessarily that
starting at this very moment,
the Supreme Court cannot stop
government actions.
There are still several steps
that need to be taken.
And ironically,
one of those steps is most likely
an immediate legal challenge
to this legislation,
which will ironically be heard
in front of the Supreme Court, likely.
Now, if the Supreme Court decides
that this legislation cannot stand
because it is ironically
unreasonable in their eyes.
Then we are
set up here
for a major political crisis
here for a country
that has no written constitution.
That's partly
what's the issue here
now for these protesters.
This passing, this,
they believe, is the beginning
of the end of an independent judiciary.
This, they believe, is the beginning
of government
having unfettered power
to do what it wants
because the Supreme Court
is the only check
on the government power here.
I don't think that these protesters
are going home anytime soon.
I have a feeling
we're going to be in
for a very eventful next
few hours
as these protesters
get potentially even more riled up.
Guys had asked what will happen now
because Benjamin Netanyahu
and those who supported
it said the judiciary needed reform.
It had too much power.
Opponents say
if you take away this soul
check on the government,
then you essentially have a dictatorship.
So now exactly what happens once these
bills pass then?
So most likely will happen.
We know the Israel Bar
Association has said
they're going to file
an immediate petition
in front of the Supreme Court.
The Supreme Court can file
an injunction, a temporary injunction
stopping the legislation
from being in force.
Now, that might happen.
We have a feeling that that will happen
and then there will be a legal battle
in front of the Supreme Court
about whether this can stand.
There's a lot of unanswered
legal questions
here, meddling questions here
about what the legality of this will be.
And I think also
in the more immediate
will be, keep in mind,
as thousands of military
reservists have said,
they will not heed the call to serve
at this legislation passes.
This legislation has now passed.
So now we're going to see
whether they're going
to live up to that pledge
or whether
if they get called up for service,
if something happens on the north
with Lebanon,
if something happens with Gaza,
if something happens even with Iran,
will they call up?
Will they heed the call
to get into their jets,
to get into their tanks
and serve as board
as per their military reserve duty?
And if they don't?
Will they be arrested?
Will that be legal ramifications
for that?
These are all the questions
now on the table,
because this legislation has now passed
I was
watching very closely Israel,
of course, one of this country's
closest allies.
President Biden,
of course, is very direct
in where he stands on this
and what he thinks should happen.
Those words may have been heard,
but it didn't certainly change anything.
He does
Oh,
no, it didn't.
And we've heard from President Biden
now twice in the past week
urging Netanyahu,
urging Israeli leaders
take a step back,
take time to come to a consensus.
There's
no need to rush this happen negotiation.
But clearly, that pressure
didn't seem to have much in effect.
Remember, Benjamin
Netanyahu has not yet
been invited to the White House,
not been yet
invited officially
for that big White House visit.
This judicial overhaul
was one of those potential reasons why.
Now, we did hear from President Biden
saying that
they do it from the White House,
saying that they do expect
Netanyahu and Biden
to meet sometime in the U.S. soon.
Now, the question will be
this legislation has passed.
There was no compromise negotiation.
Will that invitation still stand?
How will this affect
us, Israel relationships?
The Israelis have been saying
for the longest time, you know,
this is our own internal debate.
This has nothing to do
with the United States.
Our partnership
with the United States is strong,
especially when it comes
to security issues.
There's a lot of questions,
though, now hanging,
especially with all
these military reservists
saying that they will not serve.
We have yet to hear,
of course, from the White House
on this legislation passing
since this has just happened
in the last few minutes.
But it could very easily affect
U.S., Israeli relations right now
with all of this
legal, political questions going on.
Absolutely.
Hadassah, really
appreciate the reporting.
So good to have you there on the ground.